naja
[Musik]
eine klosterfrau hatte ich noch nie in
meinem auto auch für schwester manuela
ist die fahrt außergewöhnlich aber nicht
wegen mir
sie holt eine ihrer mitschwestern aus
dem pflegeheim zurück ins kloster
mitglied in bis zum ältesten mitglied
wohl tun weil die gemeinschaft ist
komplett
wie schwester manuela bedürftigen
klosterfrauen heimat geben will
davon erzählt dieser film es waren
einmal drei gottesfürchtige frauen anno
1381 wurde ihnen dieses stück land hoch
über der stadt st gallen geschenkt hier
ist das kloster wodkas entstanden
[Musik]
heute ist das kloster heimat der
kapuziner rinnen sie leben ein
bescheidenes einfaches leben und sind
ohne besitz immer noch gilt für sie die
klausur
sie gehen kaum nach draußen lieber sehen
sie unter sich dem gebet und gott
zugewandt und thun im stillen gutes für
die menschen früher waren bis zu 40
frauen in der klostergemeinschaft gut
durchmischt junge und alte
vieles hat sich seither verändert nicht
nur das ist weniger sind schwester rita
ist als junge frau ins kloster gekommen
heute ist sie 84 und gehört zu den
jüngeren die zunehmend der bedürftigkeit
macht den schwestern sorgen
darum möchten die klosterfrauen in ihrem
kloster ein pflegeheim einrichten
ein wagnis mit finanziellem risiko da
hilft dir unerschütterliches
gottvertrauen
[Musik]
heute leben noch sechs klosterfrauen her
das durchschnittsalter liegt bei 80 plus
zwei weitere schwestern die zur
gemeinschaft gehören sind bereits im
pflegeheim
es sollen nicht noch mehr ins heim
müssen im gegenteil die die es bereits
sind möchten die schwestern zurückholen
[Musik]
die 47 jährige schwester manuela ist
verantwortlich für den betrieb
sie ist die frau mutter für die
klosterfrauen die sonst jedoch alle
gleichgestellt sind
es ist ein gut eingespieltes frauenteam
das hier oben am berg ist mit der vision
gutes zu tun
dieses mal jedoch aber brauchen die
frauen selber hilfe und unterstützung
für das pflegeheim projekt brauchen die
schwestern 770.000 franken viel geld für
kapuziner rinnen die selber keins haben
das sind ganz schwerer moment wo wir uns
innerlich zerrissen spüren wo wir in der
highscore bekommen wo wir wahrnehmen das
wäre jetzt unsere aufgabe da zu sein
beizustehen und doch wissen wir wir
können uns nicht mehr wer das geht nicht
mit 15 ja selber drauf schwester klara
war früher pharmazeutin schwester
manuela balletttänzerin
jetzt werden sie durch das geplante
pflegeheim zu unternehmerinnen
ein start up unternehmen würde man in
der welt draußen dazu sagen
und womöglich den guten einfall der
schwestern mit einem preis belohnen
manager in unternehmen wirtschaftsbau
alle vier ein
[Gelächter]
ich lasse mich an die hand nehmen
sozusagen an der hand neben von gott
dass er das in mir zeigt wie können sich
lösungen angehen wie könnten wir wege
gehen dass wir einerseits unseren alten
schwestern helfen können und anderen
seite aber auch armen menschen helfen
können menschen die eben auch hilfe
brauchen
das ist unsere aufgabe die nächste die
es wohl getroffen hätte die 94 jährige
schwester gertrud zwar noch fit aber
zunehmend bedürftig also meine sorge
bewiesen großes hand aber dass ich denk
da die halter willy lam andere straßen
aufgrund wo es sehr wenige und auch
ältere schwester helga folge auf mängel
sie mir und durch st villa berg und dass
ich für mich natürlich immer bitterer
maroc sie muss sagt euro fort
das leben der kapuziner rinnen ist
bescheiden
sie leben von spenden zinserträgen von
ihrem land und dem verpachteten
landwirtschaftsbetrieb einen lohn haben
die klosterfrauen nicht sie zahlen zwar
v aber das reicht nur für eine minimale
rente schwester benedikta bekommt knapp
1200 franken ahv müsste die 93 jährige
schwester benedikta ins pflegeheim
dann müssten ihre mitschwestern das heim
bezahlen zumindest den größten teil
davon
das ist für die gemeinschaft eine große
finanzielle belastung eine zu große zu
treten ist da da hilft oft schon dadurch
geldsumme sie ja das ist aber nicht so
nein weil wir sind da in dieser weise
kirchen unabhängig dass es auch wichtig
dass dass die klöster und gemeinschaften
sind dass wir nicht von der kirche
finanziert werden sondern wir sind
eigene gemeinschaften die sich selber
finanzieren müssen
hier entsteht die neue pflegestation für
pflegebedürftige klosterfrauen aus der
ganzen schweiz werden neun zimmer zur
verfügung stehen
geführt wird die pflegeabteilung von
einem professionellen pflegeheim dass
hier eine aussenstation eröffnen wird
das kommt langfristig günstiger als sein
öffentliches heim
[Musik]
noch gibt es viel zu tun
auch für schwester manuela die mehr auf
der baustelle und weniger hinter kirche
ist der größte teil der 700 70000
franken für den umbau soll so spenden
finanziert werden
aber es ist eine zahl die auf dem papier
steht ging ja eigentlich nichts bedeutet
die mir nichts sagt aber es ist
natürlich eine verantwortung wollen
viele menschen vertrauen uns etwas an
und wir wollen das beste damit machen
und wollen wirklich dass es den
schwestern nach ergehen
man kann es sich noch gar nicht
vorstellen und es sieht auch gar nicht
danach aus dass hier in einem monat die
neue pflegestation eröffnet werden kann
es ist eine wundersame welt hier drinnen
und in dieser fülle wie schön der
architekt kommt in schwärmen
red lithium unverständnis in verständnis
und einfachheit konstante umsätze sind
spektakulär aus
die decke im speisesaal ist beim umbau
eingestürzt
das kostet gleich noch einmal ein paar
tausend franken mehr als laie stellt man
sich da die frage warum hat gott dies
zugelassen zugelassen es hat vielleicht
den grund dass wir endlich die decke
prüfen vielleicht würden viel
schlimmerer schaden nachher entstehen
das würde ich denken vielleicht weiter
was uns nachher erwartet dass wir keine
zeit denn haben uns um den konvent zu
kümmern dass wir dann für andere sachen
wieder parat sein wissen es gibt so
viele gründe die wir jetzt fiktiv uns
ausdenken nach dürfen und ich denke es
ist einfach gut so wie es ist und fertig
immerhin die pflegestation kann
termingerecht eröffnet werden
so sind wir nun also auf dem weg ins
pflegeheim schwester manuela hat mich
gleich als fahrerin engagiert um geld zu
sparen
ein eigenes auto haben die schwestern
nicht schwierig aber anfangs ich glaub
es ein lernprozess am anfang war das
schon nicht so einfach vor allen dingen
in bereichen die wirklich unser denken
übersteigt ja jetzt wie jetzt zum
beispiel 770.000 franken haben oder
nicht haben woher nehmen und begleitung
da ist gott für uns im begleiten
das ist der gedanke an gott an
unendliche erleichterung weil er ist ja
in der hand habt also wenn es in seinem
willen liegt dann werden wir das auch
schaffen
und wenn es sie nicht nicht in seinem
willen ist dann wird es
[Gelächter]
drei jahre hat schwester manuela auf
diesen moment hingearbeitet nun holt sie
die erste mit schwester zurück
schwester mein vater war drei jahre weg
vom kloster notker sec zusammen mit
schwester bernadina die am nächsten tag
geholt wird
[Musik]
das geld für den umbau ihrer schwester
manuela noch nicht ganz zusammen
aber es wurde schon viel gespendet der
bevölkerung sind die klosterfrauen
offenbar nicht egal jetzt übernehmen
profis die pflege neu arbeiten auch
männer hier für die schwestern kein
problem ich tue ich mich schwer
umso schöner dass die geld ein
wiedersehen mit schwester benedicta und
schwester gertrud nach vielen jahren
sie konnten sie im pflegeheim nicht mehr
besuchen sie kommt zwar heim aber an
einen fast fremden ort alles ist neu und
sieht ganz anders aus
[Musik]
neues zimmer noch eine klosterfrau ist
eingetroffen
schwester nicola sie lebte bislang in
einem anderen kloster nicht weit
entfernt im kloster typ auch externe
klosterfrauen profitieren
für sie ist es auch günstiger als in
einem öffentlichen 1
und sie können weiter in einem
klösterlichen umfeld leben
es ist für uns sehr schmal für die
gemeinschaft und es so ein bisschen weh
und ach nur der abschied aber wir wissen
dass sie einen guten ort ist das ist
darum dass er diese immer wie doch ein
kuss nur einfach wie es geht
doch so viel wie sie die gemeinschaft
sehe ich aber war mir schon auf alpine
sie weder der frau sehr ästhetisches
gräflichen nicht so viel über die
[Gelächter]
gesellschaft in der schweiz in europa
scheint auf einem weg zu sein wo sie
überall tat das was wir jetzt 10 15
vielleicht 20 jahre voraus in klöstern
erleiden kommt auf die gesellschaft traf
zu und so denke ich mir muss auch die
gesellschaft sich hinterfragen welche
lösungen wollen wir in zukunft anstreben
wie wollen wir das alter würdig
gestaltet ist dass immer die der die
lösung
dass man spezielle einrichtungen dafür
schafft kann man auch andere
lebensformen entwickeln dass wir als
gemeinschaft teilhaben am
alterungsprozess genauso wie am neu
werdenden leben in den familien
[Musik]
zwei monate später ist es wieder ruhig
im kloster notker sec keine bauarbeiter
mehr
es wird wieder gemächlicher der alltag
ist wieder eingekehrt
die nächste aufregung steht jedoch
bereits bevor
für schwester dominika die jüngste sie
war bisher anwärterin
das heißt sie hätte das kloster
jederzeit verlassen können
jetzt will sie das ewige gelübde ablegen
und für immer bleiben
die 37 jährige stellt sich vor dass das
ähnlich sein wird wie wenn man heiratet
dass enkel die so dass ganz klar also
das haben wir schon vorstellen dass das
einem den wir sondern dieser boote gibt
will ich merke doch als ich jetzt noch
so es ist noch nicht klar
es ist ganz klar so und doch ich dann
also irgendwo wo noch wir vollkommen es
werden muss es so sagen
auf der pflegestation leben mittlerweile
fünf klosterfrauen auch schwester
gertrud ist nun hier
[Musik]
der schläft nur alle sie vor einer gut
vom garten airline
schwester mein rat scheint sich
eingelebt zu haben
auch die andere schwester ist in der
zwischenzeit ins kloster zurückgekehrt
die 100 jährige schwester bernadina war
fünf jahre im pflegeheim
bisher geschichte bernadina wer auch
immer der andere laut ist schon brooke
astor ich glaube ja denke für für uns in
erster linie natürlich dass wir sie
wieder bei uns haben dass sie das was
ich ihm gehört aber ich weiß wo wir sie
weg geben musste das war für sie sehr
sehr schwer
das hat ja auch immer wieder uns gesagt
sonst immer wieder wiederholt darum ist
es jetzt natürlich besonders für uns
wichtig dass ja auch da sind auch hier
sterben darf
für schwester dominika gilt es nun ernst
sie wird ihr gelübde ablegen
die mitschwestern von der pflegestation
haben dabei einen logenplatz
jetzt sagt schwester dominika definitiv
ja sie wird das kloster nicht mehr
verlassen
[Musik]
zieht sie bereit sich über die ewige
profess noch einer an ihn zu bilden und
sie ihn ganz zu schenken
ich bin bereit schwester manuela und
ihrer mitschwestern haben es geschafft
sie haben ihre vision verwirklicht und
können nun allen schwestern der
gemeinschaft die gewissheit bieten
erster tot zu scheiden
hier sind auch ganz tief betroffen weil
alle schwestern heute da sind das heißt
dass wir bereits unsere schwestern aus
der pflege wieder nach hause holen
konnten
sind alle da oben und nehmen teil
und das ist für uns natürlich eines der
schönsten geschenke weil wir sind jetzt
komplett gerne kommen wie feiern sie mit
uns sie sind alle herzlichst eingeladen
danke team an
[Musik]
wenn sich der tag dem ende zuneigt dann
tun die schwestern vom kloster not kasek
was sie besonders gut können sie beten
und sie segnen die stadt und alle
menschen die hier und auf der ganzen
welt leben jeden tag und jeden abend
schaden kann das nicht
[Musik]